I do want to talk about what I think is
going on in the environmental world and
I do think it's a revolution I think for
anyone who is following the headlines of
the last week you would watch the
biggest private equity takeover in
history is the takeover of TX you a
dallas-based utility by kohlberg kravis
roberts and the texas pacific group
these are two of the titans of Wall
Street the private equity groups that
are so often talked about as great
capitalist machines and so part of the
story this last week was this takeover
and the biggest private equity deal ever
but the second part of the story and
frankly getting about as much attention
is the enormous environmental aspect of
this deal this Texas utility had become
sort of the bad actor of the
environmental world they had become the
target of protest groups from Austin to
Washington and they were proposing to
build 11 new coal-fired power plants
over the next several years and this
company would have become a huge emitter
of greenhouse gases on their own these
coal-fired power plants as i'm sure you
all know or a huge source of carbon
dioxide emissions a very substantial
part of the global warming problem or
climate change problem which we now call
it so this company alone by the time
these power plants would have been built
would have been producing two percent of
all greenhouse gas emissions in the
planet so this is a staggering
contribution for one company and it's
true that Texas needs more electricity
so in some regards this was responding
to a market demand but it's also a
question of how one gets electricity and
this is going to be a critical question
for all of us on this planet what is our
energy future going to be and how are we
going to drive the cars we want the
lights we need the industry that we must
have to continue to live the kind of
lives that people want to live and I
think the the fact that this takeover
involves two big private equity groups
that not only chose to take this company
private but have committed to building
only three of the 11 power plants have
committed to ramping up the company's
solar power commitment to radically
expanding its wind power portfolio to
committing four hundred million dollars
to a five-year investment in energy
efficiency and to what's called demand
side management trying to reduce the
amount of energy that's consumed in this
area and has committed to supporting
climate change controls for the United
States mandatory climate change controls
that is a staggering set of
environmental elements to fold into a
merger takeover deal so what's going on
here have the barbarians at the gates as
they were once called of the Henry
Kravis is the original person who was
described in this book about barbarians
of the gate is the great capitalist a
mercenary of our era and has he gone
soft has he lost it has he been captured
by an environmental group greenmail
proposal and become sort of taken up by
political correctness I don't think so I
think what you are seeing is a new world
a new world where companies have to have
environmental thinking folded into their
core business strategy and I think it
represents a second thing going on and
that is a shift towards a very new
approach to environmental protection and
approach where instead of government
driving all of the activity we are going
to see the private sector increasingly
playing a major role so I want to talk
about these two revolutions the
revolution in corporate thinking that
makes environment and imperative a core
part of strategy and I want to talk
about this broader set of changes going
on in society that move us toward a new
world of Environmental Protection a new
set of ways to move environmental
progress forward so let me talk about
this broad picture first and then I'll
come back to the corporate strategy for
a long time our model for 40 years our
model of Environmental Protection has
been one where government sets standards
and government does the research
on how to meet those standards mandates
technology and this is what we talk
about is command and control regulation
government is the prime actor not only
in standard setting but in the
technology development the research and
development process so there are
eighteen thousand people at the
Environmental Protection Agency 10,000
of whom or so are working every day to
figure out what piece of technology to
bolt on the smokestack or on the
effluent pipe of all the industries
across this country and it is my
proposition to you that this is not a
good way to do environmental protection
no matter how smart they are they cannot
figure out the best approaches to
solving environmental problems sitting
in Washington or even in the EPA
laboratories that are all around the
country instead we are moving now to a
new approach to environmental protection
and is gaining momentum called
market-based environmental regulation or
economic incentive based regulation and
in this new world government sets the
standard so it's not out of the game but
it's narrower in its role it sets a
standard in a timetable for achieving
certain emissions levels or reductions
and then it shifts the burden of taking
action of creativity of technology
development on to the private sector now
the great example of this that's been
used to date I'll give a couple of them
one is the phase-out of
chlorofluorocarbons you remember these
are the chemicals that break down the
ozone layer and 15 years ago or so we
began to realize this was a serious
problem there was an international
treaty requiring us to phase out and the
question was then how should the u.s. do
the phase-out and what the government
decided to do was to tax CFCs not to ban
them but to put a tax on them that
escalated over time so it started out a
dollar per pound of CFCs used in the
second year I went to two dollars a
pound in the third year three dollars a
pound and lo and behold by the fourth
year no one was using them because it
became too expensive and what it did was
to sharpen people's thinking about the
alternatives to CFCs these by the way
were the miracle chemicals of the
1950s they were used for all sorts of
things to blow styrofoam as a propellant
for hair sprays as a refrigerant in
refrigerators and air conditioning units
so these were miracle chemicals and
people thought we couldn't survive
without them but it turned out once you
created an incentive to think about
alternatives people got very clever and
one of the great uses of CFCs was as a
way of cleaning semiconductors as a
solvent for semiconductors and I
remember going to a semiconductor
factory when I was in the Environmental
Protection Agency and it was two years
after the phase-out had begun and the
taxes were kicking in and I asked the
manager of this plant in Texas I said so
how did you solve this problem because
they had gone cfc-free he said well it
took six weeks I said well that's pretty
good people thought it would take six
years he said no i sent the engineers
off i told him cfc-free figure it out
and what they realized was that if you
clean the semiconductors quicker before
the stuff solidified you could get the
excess junk off with hot water so he
said no cfcs needed warm water and a
different timing the whole process was
changed and we've been able to go
cfc-free now so it wasn't genius
required it wasn't brought broad-based
new technology it was simply a sharp
incentive to make people think hard
about how much they needed of the CFCs
the second great example is the Clean
Air Act of 1990 set up a structure to
phase out and reduce acid rain there was
a big problem of sulfur dioxide being
released from power plants coming down
precipitating out of the sky with rain
and poisoning lakes killing forests so
the Environmental Protection Agency and
the government more broadly set up a
regime of emissions allowances that were
tradable so the power plants were all
told you're going to have to cut your
emissions in half and here are some
permits equal to half your emissions if
you can figure out how to reduce your
emissions beyond that you can sell your
excess permits that you don't need to
people are having trouble cutting their
emissions
so this is an important innovation
because it means that not everyone has
to make the same reduction not
everyone's going to cut in half some
people are going to over fulfill and
some will underperform and the advantage
of that is it saves money for people who
have a difficult time reducing they can
go out in the marketplace and by permits
and not reduce as much and for those who
are good at reducing they can do extra
work and it's very important because it
means the usual scheme which says
everyone cuts in half as soon as you've
met your target you stop thinking about
it you move on to the next issue now
with the incentive to sell your extra
permits people who are good at reducing
keep thinking about this and keep
driving down their emissions and the
overall reduction is achieved at much
lower cost and in fact at the EPA we did
some modeling of how much it would cost
to get a ton of sulfur out of the
atmosphere out of the air and we
estimated at the time it would take
seven hundred and fifty dollars on
average to get the sulfur out of the
system the electric utilities that we're
facing this obligation said oh no no way
too optimistic it's going to take $1,500
well once the incentives were in place
once was a real price to be paid for
releasing sulfur companies got much
smarter about this this is the strength
of a market-based approach facing real
payments for their sulfur emissions
companies figured out lots of ways to
cut and it wasn't the government that
had to figure it out it wasn't the
government that had to sort out what
technology every utility and all the
folks in those utilities were suddenly
facing incentives to think hard about
emissions reductions so once the regime
was up and running the first trades came
in at three hundred dollars of time much
lower than either the government or the
business people had predicted and within
a year the price was down to a hundred
and fifty dollars a ton a tenth of what
the business people had told us it would
take to get sulfur out of the system so
what it says is two things first people
are much more creative and innovative
when they face real price signals and
second it's very hard in advance to
understand all the possibilities of how
to reduce and the smartest people in
Washington couldn't figure out the best
ways to reduce emissions in fact in the
thousand hours I spent in this
regulatory
no one not the smartest folks from
industry not the best folks from EPA
none of the lobbyists suggested what
would turn out to be the critical
variable the critical way that allowed
the big utilities to reduce their sulfur
dioxide emissions at much lower cost
than any one guest and it was a railroad
deregulation now no one thought of this
because it wasn't on their minds but
once they were facing real prices for
their sulfur releases and thinking about
having to buy fancy scrubbers to get
that sulfur out of the smokestack
somebody said well why don't we just
ship low-sulfur coal from Wyoming to the
power plants the Midwest and at the same
moment deregulation to come into the
railroad industry the price dropped
hugely of shipping by rail and that's
what companies ended up doing they all
shifted didn't buy new scrubbers didn't
spend a lot of money on technology they
simply shifted to low sulfur coal and
that fuel shift allowed them to meet the
targets at much lower cost than anyone
imagined so this is why we want to make
this move to this new approach to
environmental protection that's
market-based I think we're going to see
the problem of climate change addressed
in a similar way either with a carbon
tax or with an emissions allowance
trading system in fact the European
Union has already set up an emissions
allowance trading system and what this
is going to do is incentivize thinking
broadly across society and I am
confident that we're going to see
lower-cost emissions opportunities than
anyone has imagined and much more
technology innovation because it turns
out that the government is not that good
at technology development even the
smartest folks don't have as deep and
appreciation of the opportunity set as
the regulated industries do so shifting
the burden from some hundreds or even
thousands of bureaucrats in Washington
to hundreds of thousands of companies
across the country and across the world
gives a much broader set of people to
think about the problem and to propose
ideas and test out ideas and the
business world is better at risk taking
better at trying out new things better
at pulling back when something fails and
redeploying resources in other
directions
and much better at testing success not
on the amount of money spent but on real
results achieved on the ground so we're
in the midst of this real shift of
Environmental Protection away from the
government doing all the work to a
narrow role for government and they're
not out of the game they still set the
standard as i like to say they don't
have to drive the bus anymore but
they're still in the backseat navigating
business is now in the front seat
business is in the hot seat we might say
having to figure out how to innovate and
that is one of the reasons why there is
now a huge premium on corporate
environmental strategy as we shift to
this new model of Environmental
Protection as companies are increasingly
told you figure it out and reduce your
emissions or else pay a premium to go
into the marketplace and by emissions
allowances or by technology from someone
who's figured out a better approach than
you have this is creating big incentives
to make environmental thinking part of
strategy so again regulation is a
critical driver for getting companies to
think about the environment we can't let
the government off the hook they need to
continue to press hard and one of the
problems we face in this country today
in getting thinking going is we don't
have any regulation on the big issue of
climate change the bush administration
has backed away from the Kyoto Protocol
so while in Europe there are real
emissions obligations in place companies
are thinking about this are taking
action and there is a huge amount of
money going into alternative energy
research and development into energy
efficiency options even into options to
think about carbon capture this is not
happening fully in the United States but
it's beginning to because we are moving
I think to a world of almost certain
carbon constraints the current president
won't take action I don't believe I
don't think that Congress can get a bill
through that he would sign by the next
president whether she is a Democrat or
he is a Republican will I think take
action and I say that because all the
Democrats as you might expect are
committed to much more aggressive
climate change action but so true the
leading Republican
John McCain is the sponsor of the Senate
climate change legislation Rudy Giuliani
has a strong environmental record former
governor of Massachusetts Mitt Romney
did a lot on the environment so it's a
near certainty that the next president
will return to the negotiating table and
that there will be us climate change
emissions controls in place by 2010 so
we're headed for a world of carbon
constraints and that has brought a lot
of energy to thinking now about who is
going to have the goods and services
available to change the world when these
constraints kick in and that's why I see
already lots of activity at this
corporate environment interface big
companies and small are suddenly getting
into the action ten billion dollars a
venture capital this past year invested
in what we call the clean tech industry
pollution control alternative energy
lots of money going into solar power
wind power biofuels a whole range of
things not all of it well spent by the
way the big push for corn based ethanol
is truly foolish and a huge amount of
money is going to be squandered on this
very bad answer to the problem of what's
the energy future going to look like
it's a bad answer in part because it
takes three units of fossil fuel input
to produce four units of that corn based
ethanol output a terrible energy
translation ratio it's even more of a
bad answer because there's a food fuel
trade-off as we start to use corn to
make fuel we take corn out of the food
possibilities so the price of everything
that depends on corn is going up so beef
prices are going up most tragically corn
tortillas in Mexico have boomed in price
causing lots of mexicans to be in real
economically dire straits because this
is the subsistence food and there's a
crowding out effect as people raced to
produce more corn they're making less of
other things like barley so now they
suppress a corn doubled in last year the
price of barley has gone up eighty
percent so the beer drinking crowd is
going to face some constraints as well
in any case there are better and worse
answers and what I'm excited about is
enormous amount a private sector
emphasis on solving environmental
problems this wasn't here ten years ago
and it's exciting to see it now lots of
companies trying hard to figure out the
solution to this energy future or to
provide more efficient systems for
running everything we do I'm glad to see
we've got fluorescent lights here this
is already one step forward much less
energy consumed than an incandescent
bulb we should be moving broadly to have
fluorescent bulbs or better yet LED
lighting across our society some of you
will notice that in the last two weeks
Australia has moved forward legislation
to ban incandescent bulbs ban that's the
crude old way of doing things but it's
effective because it sharpens people's
thinking it's going to say okay you're
building a new building put these lights
in don't use the old ones because you're
going to have to retrofit a few years
from now when you can't buy the bolts so
we're seeing a tremendous amount of
action and the sea change in the
business world a sea change we're not
only two people in business think about
the environment as cost to bear burdens
they have to manage regulations they
have to deal with but it's an upside
opportunity and this is again not just
venture money going to little wind power
companies or solar power companies but
the mightiest companies on this planet
committing themselves to being solutions
providers in the environmental arena
take the local company GE under its
famous CEO Jack Welch his company was a
poster child for bad performance on the
environment it failed to clean up the
Hudson and whose atonic rivers were to
dump PCBs a jack welch thought he knew
better than everyone in the EPA how to
do environmental cleanups and he fought
the EPA every day of his tenure as CEO
Jeff Immelt came in and said well forget
about that that's not the new GE settled
those cases and has committed his
company to being an environmental
solutions provider more efficient yet
engines more efficient locomotives
taking the jet engine wind turbine
technology putting it into wind power a
big new wind business a solar power
business a clean water business it's a
room
markable turn around he's selling the
plastics division that used to be sort
of the core GE because he says the
high-growth high-margin businesses of
the future are these environmental goods
and services it is a stunning commitment
of the hardest knows toughest minded
business in America GE and the same is
true of some very big businesses abroad
Siemens and Germany again a big
commitment to becoming an environment
and energy services provider technology
provider so the world is evolving very
quickly companies big and small are
seeing themselves challenged to think
about environment and I think it's not
only because of climate change that
we're seeing companies move this way
there are other constraints that nature
is imposing if you're coca-cola and
you're trying to sell soft drinks you
need a water supply and this can't be
taken for granted in every market indeed
coca-cola's face some very serious
constraints in India where it was
perceived as draining the water supplies
that communities needed so the company
has launched a big push to become a
water supply company in the communities
where its operating it has a vice
president for water the only company i
know that has a water and environment
vice president but it's so central as an
input to their core product that they
are going to become managers of water
and to provide communities with water
where they're trying to operate I think
the other thing going on is that in a
world where energy prices have gone up
there is a huge emphasis that can be
placed on eco-efficiency that pays off
now so companies have to manage their
energy consumption in ways that they
might not have had to think about before
so a lot of emphasis being put on that
and finally there are for every company
in society a rising set of stakeholders
who are asking questions about
environmental performance of course
companies that have big environmental
footprints if you're in oil business or
chemical business lots of questions are
being asked the communities you operate
in are asking questions they want to
know if you're causing harms that they
should be worried about but even
companies with a relatively light
footprint for example software companies
are finding themselves pressed on this
issue set why
because employees care about the
environment and the high-end knowledge
workers have lots of choices about where
they're going to work and who they're
going to work for and they want to align
their lives and especially their work
lives with their values and a lot of
these folks care about the environment
and are saying you know I'd rather work
for a company that takes this issue
seriously and makes it part of the
corporate culture so lots of companies
Intel for example have made big
environmental commitments in order to
make themselves attractive to those
high-end knowledge workers another big
driver is customers when your customer
asks for environmental performance you
listen so who's driving this Walmart
more than anyone else and I'm not going
to tell you Walmart's a sustainable
business I don't think it is I think
it's got some very serious issues around
its core business model I think the
outsourcing to China I think the low
wages that are paid to the workers in
this country the poor benefits that are
offered are really big issues but I
think Lee Scott the CEO believes he
can't fix those problems with his
current business model his everyday low
prices commitment depends on those but
he also was criticized for being an
environmental bad actor for causing
sprawl for these big box stores on the
outskirts of town for driving all those
trucks around and I think he concluded
he could do something about that issue
said so he has announced enormously
ambitious environmental goals that
involve dramatic reductions in energy
consumption big improvements in
efficiency big reductions in greenhouse
gas emissions and huge elimination of
waste and it's a fascinating to see him
do this it's clearly part of an imagery
branding a burnishing of the image of
the company but it's also in part
Walmart being Walmart that is squeezing
out inefficiency and costs in order to
keep prices low because how is he doing
all this waste reduction he's driving
the demands up his supply chain so he
says to everyone it's supplying Walmart
you figure out how to cut the waste and
he's told companies that I've been
working with like Unilever I've worked
with for ten years and I have never seen
him as focused on the environment
as when Walmart lays out new demands
basically they've been told whatever you
deliver to the walmart warehouse has to
go on to the customer or else you take
it home so you deliver a pallet take the
pallet home you wrap the pallet and
plastic take the plastic home and this
is forcing them to become much more
careful about how they deliver how they
produce how they distribute products so
Walmart is a huge driver of
environmental thinking and an improved
environmental performance so we are
going to see I think lots of change
coming as businesses take this issue on
and as our book lays out there are real
strategies that companies should think
about we provide lots of tools and
frameworks that I think are going to
help companies get better at this we've
argued that companies need to do issue
modeling and mapping understand what
issues they face is it climate change is
it water is a deforestation is it
chemicals think about the issues map the
stakeholders understand who cares and
why about your performance and then we
have laid out a whole set of
opportunities that I think companies are
going to increasingly have to think
about including what are the costs that
can be cut by thinking about the
environment the Eco efficiency
opportunities is it reducing energy by
cutting lighting is it taking waste out
of the system that you otherwise have to
pay to dispose of or is it cutting risks
can you manage problems in ways that
will make you a less risky business and
therefore perhaps improve your insurance
rates or the loan rates your bank gives
you or maybe have capital markets think
you're a better company because you look
less risky and then there's upside
opportunities lots of opportunities for
people to sell products that have an
environmental dimension add value to the
customer there's lots of opportunity to
put new products in the marketplace in
fact the greatest thing that companies
like to do is to put a product out into
the market that is what we call entering
new markets pace that is to say it
doesn't have
so an example of that would be the
Toyota Prius this car is so different
from other cars that when someone shows
up in the toyota dealer and is told
sorry there's not on the lie they'll
have to wait they don't go next door and
buy a Ford Taurus they wait and they
were waiting last year five and six
months to get the Prius delivered
because it was without competition and
there's a huge premium being paid as
well so Toyota is making a fortune and
sadly some of the Detroit automakers
seem to have missed this trend toward
more efficient vehicles better
performance less pollution lower
greenhouse gas emissions and that's in
fact another lesson of our book it's not
enough to think green you actually have
to be strategic about how you bring
environment to bear in the business
context so the juxtaposition of Ford and
Toyota is worth pausing one for just a
moment Ford had a CEO until recently
Bill Ford who was quite an environmental
guy he would show up at these Davos
World Economic Forum panels and talk
about green business so he was not
unaware of environment as an issue but
he was unable to get his company to be
strategic about its environmental
efforts so the big Ford initiative was
to rebuild their famous river rouge
plant just outside detroit and they
brought in a clean architect and did
natural lighting natural ventilation
even put grass on the roof only one
problem if you're an auto company your
strategic intervention is not your
factory it's your cars and that the Ford
Motor Company got completely wrong it's
selling these giant fuel guzzling
vehicles navigators and expeditions and
they got caught out badly as the price
of fuel started to rise and as the
public consciousness around
environmental issues rose up as concern
about greenhouse gas emissions began to
kick in and they have a vehicle fleet
that people do not want to buy toyota on
the other hand had made environment a
core consideration as it set out the
1990s to design its car of the 21st
century so it had not only built the
prius with its hybrid engine but done a
dozen other things to optimize
environmental performance they've light
weight of the vehicle by replacing metal
parts with carbon fiber and plastic and
new materials they have done smart
systems in the car so why it's the Prius
get good mileage not only because it's
hybrid it shuts down at a stoplight
shuts down no idling no fuel consumption
and they've got smart systems now across
their fleet and their cars are fun and
technologically sophisticated more
cost-effective and customers love them
so while Ford is teetering on the edge
of bankruptcy toyota is reporting record
profits for this last year and sadly out
there next to ford in terms of collapse
is Chrysler and GM and over on the other
side next to Toyota in terms of huge
success is Honda so this is a complete
mindset problem i would argue with our
auto executives in detroit this is a
industry sector that missed the green
wave sweeping the business world failed
to take seriously environment as an
element of strategy and are now going to
pay a huge price they are going to
shrink in terms of size and some of them
may in fact disappear one of the other
things that's been interesting is to
look at what's failed in the way of
environmental strategy and the favorite
chapter of this book from many business
people's point of view is the whole
chapter on pit bulls and failure points
and what others have done that hasn't
worked so i'll just mention a couple of
them because i think it is interesting
one is to expect a green premium people
hope that they could sell a product than
marketplace and get a big green premium
well it works in a few cases the prius
does sell for a premium but in general
we found that companies did best when
they hit the price point of the customer
delivered quality of performance that
the customer expected and then mark it
up as the third point their
environmental qualities so you can't win
if your prices wave is way higher you
can't win if you don't deliver
performance or quality you're
spit is to hit those two points and then
is the third button you push and
marketing say to the customer oh by the
way were environmentally superior to the
competition and that's what is the
kicker that brings the customer to you
rather the next company over now there
are some exceptions this when you break
out a product into whole new market
space like the Prius you can get a
premium and there are some subsets of
the consuming public that are so
environment oriented that they are
willing to pay a premium and I'll just
highlight a couple one thing some of you
may know is the huge boom in organic
food demand the price of organic milk in
this country is double the price of
regular milk and the demand far
outstrips the supply so that is one
example where there really is a new
environmental consumer out there who's
changing the picture of what companies
see in the marketplace and we tried to
dig in and do some research on who it is
that's willing to pay this premium
because it's very interesting for
companies to know whether they are
likely to be able to succeed in this
regard and we found three subsets of the
population that have distinctively more
environmental focus than the others one
is young people particularly under 25 I
have always thought that older people
might be more environmentally oriented
you know they're about to meet their
maker and they would like to get right
with the earth but no older people get
cheaper and less interested in the
environment by and large so if you're
talking in grand generalities the least
environmental oriented consumer set of
the senior citizens the most are the
under-25s for them it's so important to
be environmental that they're willing to
pay a premium they'll buy less in
because they they feel strongly about
this as a value point second is upper
middle class people high disposable
income they're the ones they'll pay the
premium for the Prius that the ones that
will buy the organic milk so upper
middle class people are price and
sensitive want to express their values
in what they purchase and third is women
on every issue that we pulled and tested
on we have a new poll coming out a
couple of weeks a women care more about
the environment than men no should we do
more on climate change sixty-eight
percent of women you know fifty-nine
percent of men should water pollution be
given more attention
forty-nine percent of women forty
percent of men you whatever issue you
ask more women than men now to avoid
becoming a Larry Summers so problem I
won't try and go into the deep reasons
behind it but I simply report this as an
empirical observation that women care
more than men about the environment and
if you're in a company you're selling to
women you have a better chance of
getting a price premium that if you're
selling to men so look for example at
the UK clothing and food company Marks
and Spencer announced last month a huge
environmental branding initiative why
because their target audience is younger
upper middle class women so this is a
triple hit from this intensity of
interest around the environment and this
is something else companies are
increasingly doing is branding with the
environment to get to a target audience
other pitfalls I think companies have to
learn to avoid one would be
misunderstanding your market there's a
famous example of interface carpet led
by a real pioneer in the green business
movement CEO ray anderson and he had
this vision that companies would lease
carpet so we'd come in and lay the
carpet rent it to the company for five
years and come take it back recycle it
and bring them a new least carpet well
this business never literally got off
the ground it turned out no one wants to
lease carpet there are a whole lot of
accounting reasons why capital
write-offs are allowed for big
investments up front it never worked on
but Ray Anderson is a smart guy he's
moved away from that model and he's done
other things have been brilliantly
successful he sent his design crew out
into the forest and told them to be
inspired by nature yeah never thaw my
god this guy's a lunatic now why do we
have to have a CEO who's such a green
wacko they came back with an idea again
his core businesses floor tiles for the
office what turns out one of the huge
problems that's an environment and a
dollar problem is Miss laying carpet
failing the line patterns is the waste
having to tear things back up so they
developed a carpet tile line called
entropy which inspired by nature every
tile is different the patterns can be
mixed in that
in any way and this turns out to be a
huge game because you don't have to slow
down to align patterns which slows the
installation process a lot you don't
have waste by misalignment that you have
to tear up so you reduce the
environmental burden of waste and it
saves a lot of time and money so it's a
time money and environmental improvement
and this has become a huge bestseller
for them so one of the other lessons is
if at first you don't succeed you've got
to keep trying and companies are
increasingly finding that so the bottom
line and i'll close with is an answer
questions is it turns out that some of
the literature in this corporate
environmental strategy arena a lot of it
has been wrong it's been superficial and
when we launched this book we studied
all the books articles and case studies
that have been done about business in
the environment we found shockingly that
ninety-five percent claimed win-win
opportunities good for the environment
good for economic purposes good for
competitiveness and when we went back
and looked at these case studies it
turned out that most were exaggerated
it's actually hard to go green there are
real trade-offs there are real costs and
you have to think about this in a very
careful systematic strategic way in
order to achieve success and I think the
companies that we've spent time with
said that to us time and time again and
if this book is making a difference and
I think it is I think it's going again
some real traction in the marketplace
it's because we don't say it's easy we
say it's hard and we try to provide
guidance on what works and what doesn't
work and I think people appreciate the
fact that we've been honest about that
and not simply cheerleading for the
environment we will we also and I think
this is another part of the success have
written this in a style that's very
businesslike using business language
business terms business vocabulary not
environmental terms so this is not
environmentalists lecturing to business
this is business people writing to
business in a tone that they will take
on board and I can't tell you how many
business people have come to me and said
you know this is what we most appreciate
we are so tired of the haranguing from
the environmentalists that we can't even
hear it we can't even hear the message
and yet another lesson of this book is
it almost all business p
we'll want to do the right thing now the
number one reason when we ask people why
they were doing the environmental thing
that they were doing was because they
said they wanted to do the right thing
number two they found ways to save money
cut costs all these other things but
almost all business people with the you
know exceptions like Lee Raymond who
just retired as CEO of Exxon Mobil you
know he still threw his dying day will
probably go out thinking the environment
is a big waste of time and a joke but
even the new head of Exxon a rex
tillerson who took over a few months ago
has turned the company dramatically away
from its bad old ways I'm not saying
they're going to be winning any prizes
anytime soon but he's cut the funding to
the anti environmental groups that they
were funding to cut to try and cloud the
picture on climate change he's committed
the company to taking action on these
issues so even the baddest of bad actors
is I think now involving towards a new
understanding that environment matters
the public cares if you're trying to
sell to the public you better think
about it and that as a result there's an
imperative for corporate strategy to
fold environmental thinking in so let me
close there and say I it's a pleasure to
be with you it's exciting to be part of
what I think is a revolution here to be
moving the world towards some new
approaches to environmental protection
it's a great joy to have an opportunity
to write a book like this and it's a
really a joy to have the support of a
place like Yale and to have this lift go
center willing to help me give this
revolution a higher profile so thank you
very much